hey 42 here lots of people go through a
rebellious phase at some point in their
teenage years i had several friends who
took up smoking for example and the guy
in my class at school got heavily into
death metal to get back at his parents
for forcing him to take flute lessons i
wasn't immune to this particular teenage
rite of passage either
you wouldn't think to look at me now but
for six months when i was about 14
i drank my tea without even using a
coaster
as shocking a crime as that may be it
pales in comparison to the cape as a
certain young american by the name of
coulson harris moore got up to during
what was quite simply the most
spectacular rebellious phase of all time
in fact calling it a rebellious phase
doesn't really do it justice
international crime spree would probably
be a better way of putting it
when the police finally caught up with
colton in 2010 he had a ten thousand
dollar bounty on his head and the
charges brought against him read more
like the plot for grand theft auto 6
than something a single human child
could ever actually have done in real
life
this is the frankly ridiculous story of
colton harris moore better known
as the barefoot bandit
all the best criminal masterminds have
an origin story and colton harris morse
is a particularly sad one that goes a
long way towards explaining how he came
to be one of the most prolific and
daring teenage criminals in history
before he acquired his intriguing
nickname more on that in a minute by the
way colton harris moore was just a kid
like any other growing up on kimono
island in the puget sound off the coast
of washington
according to most accounts colton's
childhood was pretty bleak he grew up in
a trailer nestled deep within one of the
many forests that can be found in the
center of camano island
and just to give you a taste of the kind
of vibe that was going on at home
at the bottom of the drive was a sign
reading
if you go past this point you will be
shot
yeah
colton's family was shall we say
dysfunctional his father was allegedly a
heroin addict he was sent to prison for
attacking colton when he was just 12
years old and his mother was an
alcoholic with a few so short she made
joe pesci's character in goodfellas
looks like a mormon
social services were called out to the
trailer as many as a dozen times during
colton's childhood
but for one reason or another nothing
ever came of it quite understandably
colton wasn't all that big a fan of
chilling out maxing and relaxing at home
and so from as young as seven he started
to sneak off into the woods often
staying there for days on end
the stealing that would come to
characterize pretty much the whole of
his young life started simply as a way
to stay alive
there was never much food in the fridge
at home and colton learnt early on that
other people's fridges were usually more
generously stocked he also stole
blankets clothes and other supplies to
help him survive during those long
nights he spent under the stars
when life at home got to be a bit too
much
in those early days colton wasn't
exactly the master thief he would become
in later life he was caught stealing on
multiple occasions with each misdemeanor
earning him a week or two in juvenile
detention
but as is often the case with most
things in life if you want to get really
good at stealing stuff a little practice
goes a long way
and boy did colton practice
it's hard to say exactly when he crossed
a line from i'm stealing this because i
need it into i'm stealing this because i
can
but soon enough colton was pilfering
pretty much everything that wasn't
nailed down to the floor
he was suspended from school numerous
times for stealing and his classmates
soon dubbed him klepto cult
by the time he turned 16 the scope scale
and frequency of colton's burglaries had
increased significantly and he was
routinely breaking into expensive
holiday homes that can be found along
kimono island's various beachfronts but
it was while breaking into one of these
in 2007 that he was caught red-handed
after neighbors spotted lights on in a
house that was supposed to be empty
and called the police
colton found himself facing no fewer
than 23 different charges of theft for
which he was ultimately sentenced to
four years in juvenile detention
[Music]
much to everyone's surprise klepto cult
seemed to change his ways during his
time inside
or at least he managed to convince those
in charge that he had because after
about 12 months he was transferred to a
minimum security facility to serve out
the remaining three years of his
sentence
with the benefit of hindsight i can
confidently say that minimum probably
wasn't quite the right kind of security
for a boy like colton
and soon enough he'd escaped
still only 17 at the time he would spend
the next two years living as a fugitive
during that time colton was almost
constantly on the move
only he knows exactly where he went and
when during that time
but he's thought to have traveled
through washington idaho south dakota
nebraska iowa illinois indiana and parts
of western canada
sometimes moving on foot and sometimes
stealing cars
he was rarely sighted but police were
able to piece together at least some of
his movements by the inevitable rash of
break-ins that would be reported
wherever he went
[Music]
despite these tantalising clues colton's
exact whereabouts remained frustratingly
difficult to pin down
in fact he may as well have been a ghost
what the police didn't know is that
colton had essentially become nocturnal
and was spending most of his time living
off the grid
only venturing into built-up areas to
steal what he needed to survive
well sort of he probably didn't need
that six thousand five hundred dollar
set of night vision goggles that he
bought using a stolen credit card but
hey you never know when something like
that might come in handy
especially when you're a nocturnal
fugitive
if coulson had been content to lay low
who knows how long he might have been
able to evade capture
but his natural caution was
counterbalanced by an almost alarming
willingness to take risks in order to
get what he wanted
he'd break into homes for the most
trivial of reasons to take along soak in
the bath or to watch tv
and if he found any given house to be
empty
sometimes he stayed there for days or
weeks on end
ordering survival gear to his borrowed
front door using stolen credit cards
but
of all the many crimes colton committed
during his time on the run
there's one that epitomizes his utter
fearlessness more than any other
stealing airplanes
colton was a self-confessed flight nut
and he stole his first plane a cessna
182s at the age of 17. the idea of a
teenager strolling into an airport and
nicking an airplane might sound pretty
crazy but it's positively insane when
you factor in the minor detail that the
first time he stole a plane klepto cult
had no idea how to actually fly one
in fact rumor has it he'd never even
been in a plane not even as a passenger
how the hell he managed to get that
cessna into the air and perhaps more
importantly back onto the ground again
afterwards is a genuine mystery to this
day
media reports from the time claim he
taught himself to fly through a
combination of reading manuals he bought
on ebay and practicing on flight
simulators but colton himself has
claimed he simply figured it out as he
went along
whatever the truth each flight was
meticulously planned and executed
colton would stake out an airport for
days on end before making his move
absorbing as much information as he
possibly could about airport security
shift patterns plane types and points of
entry
when he figured out which plane he
wanted to steal and how he'd spend weeks
figuring out a flight plan if he was
expecting to land during the night he'd
simply find a quiet airport and do
exactly that
but if he planned to land during the day
he'd use google earth to scan for likely
landing spots once he figured out where
he wanted to touch down colton would
digitally scout the surrounding terrain
so that when he was safely on the ground
he'd know exactly where to go next
something that was especially important
since a downed aeroplane in the middle
of a field was bound to attract police
attention fast
using these methods colton successfully
stole and flew no fewer than five
different aircraft during his time as a
teenage fugitive as word of these
outrageous antics began to hit the news
colton achieved genuine anti-hero status
particularly amongst young people with
facebook pages dedicated to the barefoot
bandit attracting tens of thousands of
followers
by the way if you're wondering what the
whole barefoot bandit thing was all
about the name came from reports that
colton liked to commit his various
crimes
sans shoes and socks
in truth that was more of an occasional
thing than a genuine modus operandi but
as his fame grew colton started to play
up to his moniker after breaking into a
grocery store in early 2010 he took the
time to draw dozens of feet on the floor
in chalk before making his escape
and he's known to have left at least one
enigmatic crime scene note that was
signed colton harris moore aka the
barefoot bandit
despite apparently enjoying his growing
notoriety it was starting to become a
bit of a problem the authorities weren't
overly impressed with the number of
rings that were being run around them by
an upstart teenager and the longer
colton remained at large the more
embarrassing the situation became in an
effort to ends the farce the police sent
sniffer dogs swat teams and helicopters
armed with infrared cameras after him
none of these methods proved effective
but colton must have realized the noose
was tightening around his neck
which is probably why he decided it was
time to make one last bold play
the first signs of what that play
involved came with reports at a plane
stolen from an airport in bloomington
indiana had been located apparently
abandoned by the person who'd taken it
most of colton's flights to this point
had been fairly short usually no further
than to a neighboring state
but this time was different
because the people who found the
abandoned airplane weren't from ohio or
illinois
in fact
they weren't even american
colton harris moore the barefoot bandit
a self-taught pilot with no formal
navigation training had flown a tiny
single engine aeroplane more than 1
200 miles to the bahamas
specifically to the island of great
abaco
as was usually the case when colton
showed up somewhere soon enough the
locals started noticing things going
missing with dozens of houses and
businesses reporting break-ins in quick
succession colton had become so famous
at this point that it wasn't long before
pretty much everyone on the island knew
the barefoot bandit was in town plenty
of people were upset
but plenty of others were flat out
excited one local girl even attempted to
secure a date with colton through his
ever expanding facebook fan page
and considering the fact that one of the
few times he was sighted on the island
was whilst buying a drink for a girl in
a bar
it's possible he actually took her up on
the offer
but if the authorities in america had
been embarrassed by carlton's general
refusal to get himself caught like a
normal person
it's safe to say they were positively
[ __ ] bricks at the force of him
flaunting their inability to apprehend
him on an international scale
the fbi promptly stuck a ten thousand
dollar bounty on his head to be paid out
to anyone who provided information that
led to his arrest flying to the bahamas
had been a bold some might say brilliant
move
but great abaco isn't a particularly big
place nor is its population all that
large
realistically the situation was only
ever going to end one of two ways
even with coulson's capture or his death
[Music]
during the epic james bond style
speedboat chase that brings this story
to an end
both of those possibilities seemed
equally likely
colton stole two different speedboats as
he sped from island to ireland with the
police in hot pursuit he's somehow
gotten his hands on a gun at this point
a fact that doesn't seem to have been
lost on the police
they rained down bullets on colton from
behind eventually shooting out the
engine on his boat and leaving him
stranded
for the first time in two years
colton found himself with nowhere to
hide
according to some reports when he
realized it was all over colton put a
handgun to his head and threatened to
end things on his own terms though
colton himself denies that part ever
happened
either way
he was brought in safe sound and
brilliantly barefoot
one of the first things the arresting
officers did was place a pair of
trainers on his feet almost as though
they thought by covering them up they
were robbing colton of whatever voodoo
it was that he'd been using to evade
america's finest for the previous two
years straight
for his antics in the bahamas colton was
sentenced to either three months in jail
or a 300 fine unsurprisingly he opted
for the latter but far weightier
punishments awaited him on his return to
america
where he was accused of committing
approximately a hundred different thefts
alongside a slew of other charges
like all trials of this magnitude there
was a lot of legal chewing and throwing
going on
but when the dust had settled colton was
sentenced to seven years in prison that
might sound like a fairly lenient
sentence considering all the fuss he'd
caused
but colton's extremely difficult
childhood was seen as a mitigating
factor in his subsequent crime spree as
was his age where many of the crimes
were committed
in the end he served fewer than five of
those years and on his release in 2016
the attorney who defended him during his
trial hired colton to work at his law
firm a solid indicator of just how much
good will colton had accumulated at this
point in spite of his remarkable career
as a teenage criminal
these days by all accounts he's an
upstanding member of society who's put
his rebellious teenage years firmly
behind him
though in 2016 his parole officer did
force colton to end a crowdfunding
campaign aimed at raising enough money
for him to get his pilot's license
too soon colton too soon
to this day the story of the barefoot
bandit remains a polarizing one and for
obvious reasons on the one hand colton
was an apparently heartless criminal
he practically turned stealing from
others into a game
on the other hand it's pretty hard to
blame someone with colton's upbringing
for going off the rails a bit
okay a lot
but still
colton genuinely does seem to want to
right the wrongs if his criminal past
he's even got a long way to paying off
the 1.4 million dollars in restitution
he owes to his many victims
thanks in no small part to selling his
story to 20th century fox for a seven
figure sum
hey i guess sometimes crime does pay
thanks for watching